[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mcleven update the poll results if you
were the packers uh would you rest aaron
rodgers is the question and 65 say no to
start let me start there with carson
palmer uh carson packers let's say you
had to pick one they get home field
advantage in the playoffs but no rest
for aaron rodgers or
you
rest aaron rodgers for a couple of games
and he starts the playoffs completely
healthy with no home field advantage
well i don't think it's a guarantee that
if you rest aaron for a week or two
weeks or three weeks that he gets back
to 100 when you're talking about a
broken bone and a foot it could take a
month so at the end of the day when you
combine that with the fact that the
green bay packer home field advantage is
probably unlike any other in the league
i mean you got weather concerns that an
imposing team has to come in
and that that fan base doesn't sell
their tickets that fan base shows up to
the game they're not selling their
tickets to potential opposing fans where
they're going to lose some of that crowd
noise so i i think it's too important to
keep that number one seed and keep that
advantage in their favor explain this as
a former quarterback of
the pinky toe on his left foot his plant
foot as opposed to his right foot how
does that affect your throwing
i i really don't think it should affect
it that much i mean as far as as today's
you know with all the equipment and the
things and the footbeds you can put the
orthotics that you can put in the shoe
to really help protect that that pinky
toe i think that's going to be really
nice i'm sure that their training staff
is on top of that bringing in a
consultant or a specialist that can
create some sort of footbed in his shoe
to protect it
as much as possible but
where it really limits him is when he
takes off and runs it's not so much the
throwing it's not planning and stepping
and rotating into throws it's when he
needs to extend the play and get outside
the pocket and take off on third down
with his legs where the biggest concern
will be and also when you watch him
throw as you've talked about you tell
young quarterbacks don't try to emulate
aaron rodgers he has so many of those
off-balance throws he's not really one
of those i'm going to step into a throw
and plant with my left leg
no he's got that bryson deshambo swing
where right at impact and right when the
ball's coming out a lot of the times his
back foot is off the ground he's already
accelerated through the throw and gotten
his hip through the throw and that foot
comes off the ground and like you're
saying with with these young
quarterbacks there's so many guys
coaching keep all seven studs you have
seven studs on each cleat seven cleats
uh that are coming out of the bottom of
the foot of the cleat and we're always
taught as youngsters is keeping those
seven studs in the ground to get as much
ground force as you can to create as
much velocity in the throw and so aaron
just does it different i i still don't
know how he does it we need a physicist
to come in and explain it to all of us
but he very rarely has all seven studs
in the grass
we asked this question earlier in the
show you could have justin herbert or
joe burrow
who do you want i i would take herbert
right now i mean he is so special and so
so different physically athletically he
is so gifted and i'm not saying anything
about joe that that he's not i mean he
he doesn't have the velocity on and the
rpms on the football he doesn't have
the long ball ability with the touch
that justin's shown joe's got another
set of traits that are that are
spectacular his confidence
his knowledge of the game his coolness
and calmness in the pocket are
spectacular
and those are outliers compared to other
quarterbacks in the league but when you
just look at the raw talent and the raw
athleticism of justin herbert there
aren't many like him i mean maybe
patrick holmes is on the same level
there's probably another guy or two that
you can when you watch them play they do
absolutely off the charts things
physically
but right now i think i think justin
herbert has more athletic ability and
more physical uh just
physical rawness that you can't teach
you can't coach you can't show a guy how
to do he just has it can a quarterback
run too much
absolutely absolutely i mean i agree
when i was coming up in the league
michael vick was a guy i loved watching
play and still love watching his
highlights you know he ran a lot and he
took a pounding and it caught up to him
at some point and
um you know i used to joke around with
him i'd see him at different events and
even vic when he was running 4-1 he
would always get that last couple yards
going out of bounds and it wasn't a
bone-crushing hit but he would just get
shoved and then there'd be a cameraman
or a third down marker in his way and
he'd end up falling and rolling out of
bounds and landing on his shoulder and
his neck and his ankle and just all
these little incremental hits add up
especially when you talk about a guy
going into year 8 9 10 12 15. so
absolutely i think you can run too much
and take an unnecessary amount of
pounding on your body
yeah i thought michael vick was a bo
jackson like talent
but he just didn't put in the time and
the i think he had god-given ability and
i don't you know unlike like michael
jordan or you know athletes of that like
tiger they had that god-given ability
but they had this desire to be
unbelievably great and i always thought
that you know michael took it for
granted that he was just athletically
gifted and
he could have been so much better
i never felt like that uh and and i
don't know you know
individual study habits of guys and
can't comment on that but um i loved
watching him play i thought he was as
unique as talent as any of us have ever
seen there may not be another mike vick
but i i don't know as far as study
habits and desire every time i've been
around him he absolutely loves the game
he knows the game
and from coaches that i've been around
like coach mora and a handful of others
loved working with them and loved
everything that he brought to the team
watching the uh buffalo bills were
talking to carson palmer watching the
bills yesterday they kind of woke up in
the fourth quarter i don't know if they
found something after they had something
missing for the last couple of weeks
here
but i just i don't know what their
identity is carson i don't know if they
know what kind of team they are
what did you sense from what they did
first three quarters to what they did in
the fourth quarter and is that going to
change things in the last month
yeah it seemed to me like all of a
sudden they realized hold on this
we're we're about to be maybe on the
seventh
maybe the eighth spot in the afc playoff
picture and all of a sudden they started
showing up and playing
you know i i was so excited about
watching this team this year and i i'm
in the same boat i don't know who they
are i've seen them lose to some teams
they should not have lost to i've seen
them play unbelievable football but the
best teams this time of year we're in
december now we're almost in january
this is playoff football team you can't
go into a playoff game and start playing
in the fourth quarter especially against
the defending champs especially against
bruce aaron's especially against tom
brady you're going to get beat and
you're going to get knocked out of the
playoffs so you know this team has i
really like singletary the running back
i really like josh allen i really like
the defense i really like coach
mcdermott there's so many things to want
to like and believe in but they've shown
us just enough that we really can't
trust them we don't know who they are
and if they do find a way to squeak in
into the playoffs somehow someway
if they show up like that against
anybody on a playoff day on sunday
they're going to get beat like they did
yesterday
how big is this game for the cardinals
and the rams tonight
big for both i mean when you look at
both you know both those conferences the
afc and and the nfc the best divisions
are on the west you you look at what's
going on in the nfc west there's three
teams maybe that can make the playoffs
and the same thing can be said about the
afc west there might be three teams that
can squeak in so to get that number one
seed to to know that you're in and know
that when you do get to week 16 17 18
knowing that you won this division
between these two teams that are playing
tonight you know you got that in the bag
then you can start resting the 17th week
and 18th week of the season and make
sure whether it's aaron donald who's
banged up or kyler murray with an ankle
it gives you that luxury of resting
those guys if you know you have this
division locked up i've been holding off
the obvious
you got the obvious way you got the
heisman
uh not technically in in my hands yet it
is actually at the college football hall
of fame okay but they opened it they
found a way to open the heisman
they found a way to open it we've got it
thank you fedex it securely got there we
really appreciate everything fedex has
done really appreciate what your boys in
the office have done and it got home
well it didn't get home yet but it got
to safer hands than the dan patrick show
yeah and i felt bad um and i was gonna
make an example of somebody but i i
can't afford to fire somebody so
i you know i know you wanted somebody
disciplined but i couldn't do it carson
um no we're sorry we're sorry that you
went through all of this and you you got
the heisman case and you didn't even get
to open it up for your your big
induction ceremony
well i i did not want to see anybody
discipline i love fritz i love tervy i
love eric everybody is great you guys
are the best and nobody deserves a
discipline at the end of the day the
heisman got from point a to point b just
like we needed yeah and i do put some
blame on you
be because you trusted us
true he's true
you're in this like beautiful space this
little cozy den this man cave and i just
feel like everything's so professional
over there that i shouldn't have had to
worry and to be honest i didn't worry at
the end of the day it got there it may
not have got there the way we wanted or
with any kind of timing at all but it
got there
is the heisman being sent to you
the heisman currently is at the hall of
fame for another i believe another
couple months and then it'll come back
to me and um
i think it'll come back with the key and
in the correct box and and hopefully all
in one big piece yeah but you put it in
the garage you didn't even have it on
display at your house is it going to
stay in the garage again
i don't know it's i haven't had how long
have did you end up having it for like
two or three years how long did you have
it for i don't i don't remember
the fact that you don't know how long we
had it
i'm gonna guess we had it for two years
maybe
yeah yeah do you need it back
well i i don't want to do that never
mind i mean i'd love to
okay all right i would love to have it
back i mean it's great conversation
piece but the number of people go is
that the real heisman we go
yes what do you what do you think it is
and they go why would he give it to you
and i go i don't know but he did
uh we can work something out yeah and it
looks like you're on the set of a game
game of thrones episode there like you
got
basement
castle
yeah no this is just the basement uh the
basement office it is it is a little
game of thrones feeling you're right
is that the wine cellar
no it's just it's just the basement it's
the basement of the office it's a
beautiful staircase and
um looks impressive i could use a wine
cellar though yeah thank you yeah
well talk to bledsoe bledsoe can help
you with the wine
i love double back wine he's doing i
have a bunch of his wine it's fantastic
i do not have a wine cellar but maybe i
don't know maybe next time maybe if you
guys want to put a little money into the
infrastructure here we can shoot from
the future wine cellar
yeah that's that's that's what i want to
do we lose things we don't buy things
carson we're not we're not going to help
you with your basement wine cellar there
i wouldn't trust you or your crew i i
agree i agree by the way
uh the urban meyer mike brabel handshake
at the end of the game a lot of people
made a big deal about this
i
as a former player is it a big deal that
handshake after the game
it's not i mean at the end of the day
it's not but the immaturity of some of
the things that have happened in
jacksonville i mean when when it seems
like you're not as mature as some of
your players you got a problem i mean
it's just one thing after another after
another after another and it's not hard
you know cameras are on you it's not
hard to throw a smile or at least mouth
the word good game and shake somebody's
hand especially somebody that you have a
relationship
with from the past and was on your team
but um i know it's definitely there's a
bigger deal made of of what actually
happened
but at the end of the day coach meyer
just needs to at least don't you even
have to say good game you can just say
so that the cameras pick that up
and and leave your hand in the other
guy's hand for another you know six or
seven seconds to make it look somewhat
genuine but you know it seems that
things have really gone south really
quickly um i know shad khan you know
doesn't seem to have uh
you know a long leash on any anybody
that's come through that organization to
get them right i've heard tremendous
stories about the ownership group at
some point it looks like things are
going to change there in jacksonville
but but so you think if he just mouths
good game
and and just so it's the optics that we
get to see this then you're okay with
urban meyer kind of going through the
motions
i look at everything through the
quarterback's perspective and and the
organization's perspective and from my
viewpoint as the quarterback
and you're a rookie and trevor lawrence
then goes into his presser on wednesday
morning and he's asked seven questions
about urban meyer and the distractions
and the handshake
trevor lawrence needs to be focused on
the week 14 opponent he does not need to
be answering questions about his coach
telling his his staff their losers him
not shaking a guy's hand after the game
and just being professional these are
all distractions these things add up and
especially when you have a rookie
quarterback that's just trying to find
his way and figure things out the last
thing he needs to do is be distracted by
things that his head coach is doing
either outside the game and after the
game or off the field so um you know i
think at the end of the day when you
look at it through the quarterback's
perspective that's the last thing that
trevor lawrence needs to be worried
about is is in answering questions on
wednesday and thursday after practice
and friday after practice it's it's just
it these things are mounting up and it
has a negative effect on the future your
franchise in trevor lawrence more
concerned about urban meyer moving
forward or trevor lawrence
oh urban meyer 100 i mean trevor
lawrence is
what he did at the collegiate level will
give him a couple years to figure it out
in the nfl what he's done in a handful
of games will give you a little more
leniency now there was the four pick
game yesterday that those those are some
issues that they'll need to get over but
those are also things that young
quarterbacks go through and those are
some of the growing pains but trevor
trevor in my opinion has
all the upside in the world he's playing
for i know this organization has not
been great since shad khan's taken over
but he's playing for a great owner
that's willing to do what it takes to
win and willing to spend what it takes
to win and so at the end of the day when
you combine raw
talent that trevor lawrence has and he's
done it on a big stage and needless to
say that was college and that was the
bcs and in the playoffs in college and i
know it's a different game in the nfl
but he's done it against the alabamas
and some of the teams in the sec it will
soon carry over the nfl level so there
is no doubt in my mind that trevor
lawrence is going to stick around in
this league for a long time
what's it like when you lose confidence
in your coach
it's hard it's hard it's just again
these are distractions when you when
you're worried about your head coach
benching a player or
you know not playing some of your best
players to to make a statement uh when
you're worried about having to answer
questions all the time like we just
talked about you know at the end of the
day
they're going to figure these things out
they're going to get better if that's
with urban as the coach or not this the
right or ownership group it's the right
young talent they're going to figure
things out in jacksonville but did you
go through
a period where you didn't trust your
coach
i've been really fortunate i played from
from bruce arians to marvin lewis to
pete carroll i've i was very fortunate i
played for some great ones i've seen
some opposing players and talked to to
guys i played against that went through
some very urban-like situations uh with
their coaching staff or their their
coordinator and
no confidence in their coordinator
frustrations with their qb coach i've
seen it and i've seen how that can just
weigh you down especially as a young
player so it absolutely can be a
distraction it absolutely can be an
issue and the right ownership group does
the right makes the right move at the
right time i wouldn't be surprised if if
we saw a different head coach in
jacksonville next year but i wonder
about russell wilson in that situation
right now carson just feels like there's
some frustration there
it does um
but i don't think i don't think that
should directly be um pointed on pete
carroll i mean pete carroll has proven
that he can win a super bowl he's proven
that he can build
and and construct a really good defense
he's he started over man you look back
at what pete did when he first got there
and they somehow got to the playoffs and
matt hasselbeck was the guy and then he
built the legion of boom um i i don't
think that russell needs to be
frustrated with with the head coach it
looks like he's frustrated more with the
organization but it's tough i mean when
you when you talk about one of the best
organizations in all of sports like the
seattle seahawks you know you can run
out and you can want something different
but the grass is not always greener on
the other side
uh enjoy the game tonight always great
to see you thanks again buddy
thanks thanks for having me that's
carson palmer his weekly appearance
during the nfl season brought to you by
our partner level select cbd looking for
next level relief visit
levelselectcbd.com